нідерланди економічного вид |
ратифікації у води просо через Україну та
поганого з рукою та перспективою
експорт із нідерланди до України може
що збилися в 3 год
спить карамель ярду євро дуб на 4-му
години imports україни до нідерландів
рустема ж на 2 год до 1 мільярда 300
мільйонів євро
таким чином внутрішній валовий продукт
нідерландів сильний, що збився на 170
юніт
євро че правда фп це не ратифікації у
води прошу частиною ви вирішальну роль для
адже амстердама граючи на економіка мова
шляху до на референдумі ми на лузі руку
нідерландці ви славилася а про ти про суть
ati з України
то гітарі шальну роль люди голи
популісти політичних осло не мігрантам
з України не весь килим ти трентино
донбасі і нік перспективі членства
україни в ес на по роду дні
парламентських виборів я ж буду тих же
через три ти ж не політики не може їх
нарвати внаслідок референдуму
а g-точки більше надсилати шанси на
допомогу нідерландських популістів парк
ринку виходу з посади точно рішення щедро
дефекації у року амстердаму мудак волині
jet після вибору виводу про асоціацію з
україною
стала за ручну равликових з магів у
нідерландів